[Musica]
avete notato che in giro c'è una tale
quantità di rabbia tanto da essere
contagiosa come un virus
arriviamo da anni davvero
complessi prima la pandemia che ci ha
messo a confronto con noi stessi tanto
da farci diventare così antipatici e
insopportabili in alcuni momenti dice di
sì lei dice di sì poi la guerra russia
ucraina anche questo insomma che cosa
sarà domani cosa succederà il gas e la
luce è quello e quell'altro accipicchia
e poi non ultimo dieci anni fa il
terremoto che quest'anno febbraio ci ha
ricordato appunto che erano passati
giusto giusto quei dieci anni
dieci anni niente male non trovate
beh in tutti ma riflettiamo un attimo
perché bisogna fare anche questo
in tutti i momenti che scuotono ci sono
in tutti i momenti forti ci sono degli
attimi in cui che meraviglia siamo tutti
quanti insieme che bellezza mettiamo
tutto in comune paure
timori tutto poi
ad un certo punto quando tutto comincia
a girare per il verso giusto
magicabula bili di bula pouf
in noi quel bellissimo senso di comunità
che eravamo riusciti a creare torna un
milione perché ve lo siete mai chiesti
io sì e continuo a farlo ma non perché
non ho nient'altro da fare ma perché mi
piacerebbe capire un pochettino di più
allora io credo che questa domanda
potrebbe avere davvero tantissime
risposte mille forse anche di più
potrebbe trattarsi di cecità l'abilità
della memoria egoismo ma no la cosa di
cui io credo cosa che io credo è che si
tratti di mancata stabilizzazione
dell'insegnamento più profondo più
autentico di quei momenti di cui stavamo
parlando prima
credo che valga la pena vivere questa
vita in modo pieno e apprendere è
qualcosa che ci permette di vivere in
modo ancora più consapevole e
naturalmente se metabolizziamo
quell'insegnamento altrimenti
perseveriamo in qualcosa
credo anche che
la cosa che possiamo avere imparato cosa
abbiamo metabolizzato abbiamo
metabolizzato soprattutto in quei
momenti che sentirci utili è una sorta
di motore che fa andare avanti l'essere
umano ma che bello era anche durante la
pandemia sapere che qualcuno ci stava
rispondendo dall'altra parte che bello
era sapere che potevamo fare qualcosa
per qualcuno
che era anche un po noi no
allora io credo che tutto questo ci
serva anche per il senso di comunità e
credo che
sia necessario attingere ad una fonte
che è quella della gentilezza
la gentilezza
ce lo dicono anche gli studi scientifici
o ne sono andata a prendere alcuni 1 sul
corriere della sera uscito il 20 di
aprile che dice che la gentilezza
appunto fa bene ea uno studio basato
sulla kind test condotto su un'indagine
condotta su 60mila persone
dall'università del success
sostanzialmente in questo studio non è
che abbiamo scoperto grandi cose ma ci
ricorda che fare
essere ostili e rancorosi fa male alla
salute di chi prova a queste emozioni
questi mentre essere gentili fa bene sia
a chi lo prova sia a chi lo riceve
naturalmente deve essere una gentilezza
autentica che nasce dalle viscere quella
gentilezza che non chiede nulla in
cambio ma sgorga sgorga come un fiume
farebbe naturalmente ok non parlo di
fiumi di questi giorni perché c'è un
caldo bestiale
l'altra cosa che
chi per esempio prima della pandemia
questo studio di cui vi ho parlato
adesso parla appunto di un periodo
durante la pandemia invece sono andato a
prenderne uno da pub med che una fonte
piuttosto autorevole e riguarda l'appeal
quanto sia sottovalutata la gratitudine
siamo nel 2018 prima della pandemia
e in questo studio si racconta che
invece esprime gratitudine fa molto bene
sia chi le esprime chi le riceve ma
sottolinea che c'è un byas cognitivo che
cos'è un buy a sé una distorsione che
non ci fa dire insomma che ci fa credere
qualcosa che in realtà non è gentilezza
per molti è uguale a debolezza non è
così perché io credo che per essere
davvero gentili serva davvero tanta
consapevolezza e tanta forza
allora quali sono questi tre atti di
gentilezza di cui vi parlavo prima beh
il primo atto è quello verso noi stessi
sì gentile con te stesso perché nessuno
può farlo meglio di che questo è il
primo atto ma come si fa ad essere
gentile con se stessi rispetto rispetto
per il tempo rispetto per chi siamo
rispetto ma anche rispetto per i nostri
pensieri come stiamo pensando come se
non dialogando con noi stessi se io per
esempio mi dice sì antonella sentisse è
una perfetta imbecille continuassi a
ripeterne lo ripeto sarei gentile con me
stessa no
mi sarebbe più utile di armi senti
antonella ok hai fatto una sciocchezza
ma cosa ha imparato
e come vorresti migliorarti ecco questa
è la domanda più gentile anche perché mi
ricorderei anche che sono umana e in
quanto umana come tutti quanti voi io
posso sbagliare ma
mi è richiesto di sbagliare meglio di
quanto io non abbia fatto prima
il secondo atto di gentilezza che
dovremmo compiere è quello nei confronti
degli altri si gentile con gli altri
perché nell'altro c'è sempre un po di me
è invece sempre un po dell'altro young e
dice che non incontriamo le persone a
caso però per essere davvero gentili con
gli altri
noi dobbiamo avere già acquisito tanta
gentilezza nello sguardo ecco perché il
primo atto di gentilezza che dobbiamo
compiere quella verso noi stessi poi
verso gli altri
vi faccio un esempio
un giorno animata da uno stranissimo
spirito è lo spirito proprio spiritello
quello sportivo
decido di andare in bicicletta nella
piazza della mia città
c'era un'esposizione molto bella tutti
quanti di espositori con il tappetino
verde io commetto un atto indicibile
inenarrabile proprio una roba
calpesto di un ano mm il tappeto verde
dall'espositore
questo
pare trasformarsi nell'incredibile hulk
e da un momento all'altro mi urla contro
gli escono le viene dal collo i passanti
si fermano mi guardano guardano lui io
serafica lui il tuo rosso fuoco e ad un
certo punto mi insinua nel discorso
mentre lui sta per prendere fiato dico
signore mi scusi tutta questa rabbia fa
molto male lo sa e guardi e poi le dico
anche un'altra cosa se lei mi dice tutto
questo con toni gentili io farei
esattamente la stessa cosa che sto
facendo adesso chiederle scusa e
parcheggiare la bicicletta da un'altra
parte loro è incazzato come una pantera
ogni volta le spalle va a sedersi ma
cosa aveva passato questo tizio
c'è una frase molto carina di ted l'asso
una serie che è andata che va di moda
insomma chi dice di no jazzman stop si
curioso e non giudicante c'è che cosa
stava succedendo a quest'uomo io non lo
so perché dovevo rispondere la rabbia
con altrettanta rabbia che senso ha
il terzo atto di gentilezza che dovremmo
compiere è quello nei confronti di ciò
che è vita rispetto alla nostra le
piante e gli animali anche questo io lo
metto nel conto quotidiano guardate la
gentilezza e anche gratitudine per la
bellezza che ho in che abbiamo incontro
m io stavo venendo qua ad un certo punto
il mio sguardo viene completamente
rapito da una fila di alberi che
facevano un disegno mera migliosi questa
e gratitudine
questa gratitudine per il fatto che io
posso vedere quella bellezza posso
sentire la posso gioirne posso essere lì
presente e viverla
allora vedete piante animali riescono a
essere gentili in modo assolutamente
gratuito nei nostri confronti ma voglio
spendere una parola per questo per
questo esserino
allora lui è arrivato al mio cospetto
esattamente un anno fa
era una palla di pelo di tre etti e tre
settimane con 40 grammi di pulci addosso
puzzolente come una foglia di calcutta e
mi è stato portato da un amico cioè è
arrivato per caso ci siamo guardati ci
siamo innamorati e successo tutto in un
lampo io faccio una vita con un po
incasinata e avere anche questa palla di
pelo che dipende assolutamente da me è
un po impegnativo però abbiamo iniziato
a fare quella cosa che alcuni chiamano
pet therapy io quando la faccio lui la
chiama human therapy chissà se gli piace
non lo so sta di fatto che siamo gentili
gli uni luna con l'altro perché lui un
maschietto è
lui a gentile persino con il mio divano
è una notizia meravigliosa
ecco allora gentilezza e anche
reciprocità e rispetto e prendersi cura
gentilezza è è tanta roba come dicono i
ragazzi oggi e gratitudine perdono e la
capacità di guardare oltre le capacità
di essere qui e la capacità di dire
grazie ciao prego scusa
poi sapete che nel nostro paese abbiamo
più di 150 assessorati alla gentilezza
no
e invece ne abbiamo anche cinque in
emilia romagna
nascono tutti quanti da un progetto cosa
cosa fa l'assessore la gentilezza
assessora la gentilezza di fondo fa
questo cerca in qualche modo di limitare
la violenza fisica e verbale nella città
cerca in qualche modo di
convalidare progetti relativi alla
gentilezza anche da insegnare bambini
nelle scuole perché quello che si
vorrebbe fare tutto questo è partito da
una fondazione e l'associazione tutto
quello che si vorrebbe fare è far
diventare
la gentilezza il senso di una comunità
noi dobbiamo imparare anche a parlare di
sostenibilità umana si ok parliamo tanto
di sostenibilità ambientale ma dobbiamo
imparare anche a parlare di
sostenibilità umana perché il pianeta è
abitato dall'uomo e io sono fortemente
favorevole alla sostenibilità ambientale
ma in un viveur armonico e allora come
disse è la la mamma di cenerentola
nell'ultimo walt disney
come scrisse anna frank e nel suo diario
è lei insomma una storia un po scomoda
l'ha avuta
sii gentile e abbi coraggio
insegniamo la gentilezza e cerchiamo di
spargere questo bellissimo seme a
cominciare da noi
[Applauso]
[Musica]